RAF recruitment has been under Fire for
weeks it started when the head of
recruiting resigned in protest at an
alleged order to prioritize ethnic
minority and female candidates over
white men
there have also been claims the Air
Force inflated diversity figures then
over the weekend a former RAF pilot
published a leaked email on his YouTube
channel
just get this straight if they select
based on Merit that's going to be a
problem for the Royal Air Force because
they have targets they need to achieve
set by the chief their staff
written by an officer based here at Raf
cramwell the email from April last year
discussed how the Royal Navy was
developing a scoring system to rank
candidates according to Merit
it said the ref could certainly use this
on occasion but the email went on I
still hold the view that moving to a
merit-based sift using scores achieved
from assessments for candidates would be
problematic for the RAF with huge
implications on how we do things to
achieve our targets
finally the RAF for the first time has
admitted there had been mistakes
a spokesperson said well overall
standards did not drop in hindsight we
accept that despite the best of
intentions some mistakes were made
the RAF is now confident that our
approach is correct however we are
investigating some processes and
decisions taken in the past
it would be inappropriate to comment
further while this is ongoing all I
would like is an apology for all the
young white men out there the British
white men who put a lot of effort into
education researching the service they
got themselves to a level and I know
they did because I trained boasted them
in my school to present in front of the
airports and they would never give me
the opportunity primarily only because
of the color of their skin and the sex
they were born
Sky News is K Burley earlier this month
repeatedly asked the head of the RAF
what has happened to those responsible
for the recruitment practices
we will do that without any drop of
operational status we will be very clear
we will be very clear about how we how
we uh how we approach any attempts to
widen that pool Talent widen our
diversity and we will continue to to
protect the nation uh we we will secure
our skies and Patrol our seas as the RAF
focuses on its Core Business of Defense
an inquiry has been launched following
the resignation of the head of
recruitment
more details are expected to emerge once
that concludes Deborah Haynes Sky News